each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay uh let's get started it's my
pleasure to welcome renji jolla so many
of you already know and jeet pretty well
he's a professor at UC San Diego and
he's been doing a lot of really cool
stuff on ensuring that the software we
use is very reliable so we'll tell you
about some of the stuff he's done there
okay thanks Trish soon um hang on let me
just figure this out this goes next this
points but none of my hands will be free
then okay so I'm you know I'm not going
to tell you about why I do this because
I'm and Microsoft Research now so we're
just going to cut to the chase I work on
tools that check properties of software
okay so let me let me just you know get
started right away and what I'm going to
tell you about in this particular talk
or if i get time for it to two distinct
lines of work that i've been working on
over the last few years one is on on
work on static safety verification okay
so how do you verify assertions of the
programmer might put in their code and
the second is a is a scheme for
dynamically checking liveness properties
it turns out that these on this doesn't
point it turns out that safety
verification is very nice for somewhat
simple low-level properties but these
algorithms don't really work when you
want to enforce lightness and so and so
we developed a separate scheme which
which essentially uses a kind of random
walk approach to find liveness bugs so
hopefully we'll get to talk about both
of these things but we shall see okay so
let me leap right into safety
verification and I'm going to give you a
little bit of background there's
probably stuff that most of you are
quite familiar with but it'll just sort
of set the stage for what comes in the
future okay so I'm going to make a very
canonical safety property which is
memory safety so here's a he has a very
small program it actually does something
I forgot what it does or it copies a it
makes a copy of an array a and it can
okapis it into an array B it's not
really relevant what exactly is going on
the key point is at this line over here
there's an access
you know where we're touching to erase
we are touching the Arabian another
array and we would like to know that
this access happens within bounds this
particular right happens within bounces
between you know zero and the length of
that particular array and of course as
you all know if you can't ensure these
things if it can be that the that this I
is outside the bounds of the array then
various charitable things start to
happen it allows it allows bad guys to
hijack your machine etc etc ok so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to use that
as a kind of very simple example and
then we will build on a more complicated
example and what I'm going to do is sort
of outline the three steps in which I'm
going to look at this problem of safety
verification ok so first what I want to
do is to very crisply formalize this
notion of array bounds ok or a rebounds
checking and sort of describe it as a
very generic safety property and then
i'll show you how one builds algorithms
to check those properties so let's go
back to that little program so i have b
of is assigned a of jail and here's the
rest of the program i'm going to
simplify various things right for
example what i'm going to do is I want
to check at that point that the variable
i is between 0 and n where n is the
length of the array be ok so I'm just
making very simplifying assumptions and
then the further simplify it's very easy
to see why I is greater than 0 it was
initially 0 and then we keep bumping it
up this is good we should only have one
of these ok we keep bumping it up so I'm
going to drop that part of the conjunct
and then I'm going to throw out all this
stuff about Matlock and so on and so
forth to keep this example very simple
ok so with all of this we're down to
this tiny little program it has just
three lines 0 1 2 and at this point I
have an assert that I want to prove i
want i want to ensure that at this
particular point the variable i is
always less than n right so this is
something we're all very familiar with
how can I prove that this assert never
fails so now let me show you how one
goes about designing an algorithm again
this is something that most of you are
going to be very familiar with so you
know I just want to kind of get the get
the ground rules straight which is we're
going to find invariance right this is a
it's a decades-old idea and what is an
invariant quite simply it's a predicate
that is guaranteed to hold at each of
each particular program points and this
example the environments are going to be
off this form I'm going to say that at
program point zero in general I know
whatever precondition is guaranteed
before this program starts executing in
this case let me assume that I don't
know anything about what the program
variables are and so the only fact that
I'm guaranteed is going to be true is
the fact true okay so simple enough at
this particular point if you stare at it
for a bit what you'll see is that
whenever the program is on line one the
sum of i and j is equal to n minus 1
right it's initially n minus 1 every
time around the loop you bump it up your
detriment it's always going to be n
minus 1 and now at this particular point
since I enter the loop i know that the
sum is equal to n minus 1 and j is
greater than 0 okay and as a consequence
of these two facts of this invariant I
know that n is going to be greater than
I right because the sum is equal to n
minus 1 which is less than n and j is
greater than 0 so so i must be less than
n so far so good very well so that
particular invariant proves the assert
and so how do we prove these asserts all
we have to do is figure out appropriate
program invariance at each program point
okay so many of you have been working on
this problem for a while so this should
not come as a big surprise so here's the
approach that he has a very sort of
well-known approach what we're going to
do is we're going to to figure out the
asserts we're going to use sort of you
know middle school algebra which is we
don't know what the invariants are at
each point so I'm going to introduce a
variable let me call it X sub I at which
is going to represent the invariant at
line I ok so i have x 0 x 1 and x 2 are
the invariance at each of these three
points and next what I'm going to do is
figure out what are the relationships
that must hold between x0 x1 and x2 so
that you know they they there they are
actually valid invariance and they surf
ice to prove this assertion ok so please
at this point I should have said nothing
surprising but you should stop me
whenever I was it will soon get slightly
more complicated I promise you but
please stop me whenever you get lost ok
if there's something you don't follow or
if you think I'm lying ok x0 x1 x2 so
let's try and figure
out what are the properties what are the
relationships that these guys satisfied
okay so as far as x0 is concerned we
know that X 0 is the represents
invariant at line 0 I have no idea what
the variables are at that point what
values they have the initial values or
arbitrary so I'm just going to say that
the invariant at x0 is true it's just
you know it's the precondition that
holds when the program starts executing
so it's just true very well what about
what happens after we just do this
assignment I is equal to 0 well at this
particular point sorry when we're over
here I know that well true is true and
in addition I is equal to 0 right
because I just assign I the value zero
size going to equal to 0 and then what's
going to happen is I'm going to do the
second assignment where j is a sign n
minus 1 and so i end up at line one
where i is equal to 0 and j is equal to
n minus 1 okay well this is one
execution that's led to line one and so
the invariant that line one must hold
and so I end up with this particular
relationship that I equals 0 and j is
equal to n minus 1 must imply the
invariant headline one ok so this
implication must hold let's move along
I'm at line one and I know the invariant
x1 holds when i get to line two what I
know is that x1 is going to be true and
in addition since I only come in when j
is greater than zero I have that at line
to this fact holes ok but I'm at lying
to an edline to the invariant x2 must
hold and therefore j equals greater than
0 and x one must imply x2 right that's
yet another constraint now what happens
at line too well we have this assertion
and so x2 must imply that I is less than
n right because we want this we want
that at this point is you know between 0
and n so the invariant at lying to
mustn't implies less than n and finally
when I jog down this the the body of the
while what I have is that at this point
I'm back I know x 2 is true and then I'm
going to increase I and I'm going to
decrease J by one and so at this
particular program point what I'm going
to know is x2 with the values of j and i
replaced with some old values i 0 and j
0 and the new values of I and J are
respectively the old values plus 1 and
the old value minus 1 right that's what
I know at this particular program point
and your control flow
back up to one little loop and so this
this formula over here must imply the
invariant at line one and so i end up
with another constraint like this my
machine has started chopping I'm sorry
this is the screensaver how does one
mute this Oh mute okay very good okay so
far so good so what are these invariants
x1 and x2 there's simply predicates that
satisfy these four implications okay no
no big shock so far okay great so now
how are we going to infer these
invariants which is going to solve for
x1 and x2 okay and how are we going to
solve for x1 and x2 well this is a you
know sort of broadly speaking one uses a
technique called abstract interpretation
but I'm going to I'm going to propose a
specific form of abstract interpretation
called lazy predicate abstraction well
what am I going to do is we're going to
build a tree of executions over atomic
predicates okay let's not worry about
where these predicates scum from so the
nodes in this tree are going to
correspond to these variables x1 x2 and
the edges are going to correspond to
these implications each of these
implication constraints X 1 implies X 2
and what I'm going to do is I'm going to
label each of the nodes in the tree with
with some conjunction of atomic
predicates that have come out of
somewhere okay some kind of monkey
Oracle who knows what has produce these
atomic predicates I plus J equals n
minus 1 j is greater than 0 great so
let's let me just show you how this
works so here are my four constraints
down there and the root of the tree is
going to be one of these variables that
has no left-hand side so think of these
arrows as a kind of child relationship
x0 doesn't have a parent so that's X 0
is going to be my route and at each step
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
pick one of these constraints and I'm
going to sort of unroll that constraint
thereby adding a child to this tree okay
so I start off with x0 is true and i'm
going to pick that particular constraint
and here's what I'm going to do I have
to figure out what predicates can i
assign to x1 what invariant shall I
assigned to x1 and to do to find this
out i am going to build on the work of
many of you guys over here which is to
say i'm going to use an smt solver okay
so I'm going to ask an smt solver I have
this left hand side which says I is
equal to 0 and j is equal to n minus 1
and X 0 which is
right so which of these facts can I
prove which of these facts hold and the
SMT solvers going to say you know I plus
J is n minus 1 this this implication is
valid so I'm going to say ok that's good
what about the next implication the SMT
solvers going to say no that implication
is not valid and so we're going to say
ok I can label x1 with this fact i plus
j is equal to n minus 1 ok and we keep
doing we keep we keep repeating this
process so now I'm going to add I'm
going to focus on this particular
constraint JS greater than 0 and X 1
implies X to this time when i asked the
SMT solvers going to say yes this
predicate continues to hold and this one
also holds because of that of that
conjunct over them so i can label x 2
with those two now I have this I have
the assertion down there x 2 in implies
i is less than n again i'm going to ask
the assembly solver this question can
you prove this implication and the SMT
solvers going to say absolutely i can
prove it life is good ok this
implication is valid I'm going to jog
down and here's my you know that that
find that messy constrained i'm going to
ask it which of these facts are true I i
know that i plus j is equal to n minus 1
and j is greater than 0 essentially i
bump up I and I decrement J and so the
SMT solvers going to be able to say this
fact continues to hold but j is greater
than 0 no longer you know I can't say
that for sure because we just decrement
the gym ok so i'm back and i'm here with
the the label i plus j is equal to n
minus 1 x.x one has this label and at
this point we can stop this process of
unrolling ok because essentially what's
happened is I've seen I see exactly the
same I see the same node X 1 and it has
exactly the same labor so if I keep on
rolling this tree i'm just going to keep
getting isomorphic copies of the stuff
I've seen so far if I can chop off the
unrolling at that particular point and
in fact at this point i found an
assignment of formulas to x0 x1 and x2
that satisfy all of those constraints ok
and so I found the invariance that I
want to do to start with ok so it's all
good I proved the assertion life is good
there was a small catch where do the
where do the hang on
just when I said there's a small catch
all right we're gonna we're gonna need
backup on this oh look at managed to get
it wedged in there okay um there's a
small matter of where do you find these
atoms where did this I plus J equals n
minus 1 comes from and I'm not going to
tell you about the details of this you
know this is a kind of fairly well
understood technology at this point you
start with no atoms then you use counter
examples in an idea that was popularized
right here but I mean there's a question
about where exactly do squeeze the atoms
out from and it turns out that you use a
fancy logical technique called Cregan
turbulence and you can get atoms like I
plus J equals n minus 1 out completely
automatically okay so far so good okay
so this is just so kind of brief
background a quick recap of of how
safety verification has worked in the
past which is to prove safety you need
to find invariance x0 and x1 x2 etc at
each program point how do you find these
invariants you generate a bunch of these
implication constraints and then you
solve these implication constraints
using some sort of predicate abstraction
yeah okay what is for the influence is
it very similar to the movie any
alternatives like if I think of poutine
yes you can think of it as easy as well
that's also actually Houdini is a kind
of you can think of it as a kind of
Cartesian predicate abstraction ok so
this is all well and good but this
pretty much assumes that you know
programming languages have not changed
since the 1960's because we're you know
basically writing programs with integer
valued variables and loops and we're
doing these you know little fidgety in
arithmetic operations but there's a
whole world beyond that ok in particular
you have things like threads you have
asynchronous events and then you really
start getting into the modern era with
things like higher-order functions
polymorphism generics fancy data
structures trees hash tables maps etc
etc and things like pointers aliasing
mutation and so on and so forth right
and so how does one deal with all of
these complications automatically this
is the this is really the question that
I've been focusing on for the last
couple of years and what I'm going to
tell you about is some work that I
did that addresses that looks at that
looks at the question of polymorphism
higher-order functions and data
structures and let me tell you what what
the main idea is and then I'm going to
launch into a demo ok so the outline for
the rest of the talk is I'm going to
give you a high-level idea of what's
going on then I'm going to show you a
demo that illustrates how this works in
practice and then i'll switch back into
didactic mode and I'll sort of pick up
the pieces of what happened in the demo
ok now go into some detail ok so to
motivate the approach that that we've
taken let me first tell you what is the
problem with data structures and you
know higher-order functions etc etc let
me just use another seemingly very
innocent-looking program there's just a
while loop but we've thrown in summer
Rae's and this is this this is actually
a real program by the way this is the
canoe Morris pract string matching
algorithm okay but we're not going to
worry with that let me just focus on
this one line in the in this algorithm
where what we're doing is I'm using the
contents of this array call table as I'm
looking up the value of the you know the
position p minus 1 and this is going to
be the next position P so already you
can see that and I'm going to use this P
in the next iteration of the loop and so
in order to prove that these are a
accesses happen within the bounds of the
array I'm going to have to reason about
what the hell i put into the array in
the first place right in particular I'm
going to need a universally quantified
invariant that says something to the
effect of every element of the table
every element that I store inside the
array table exceeds minus 1 okay because
yeah wait plus 1 whatever it's this is
why her off by one areas it is my it is
minus 1 actually yes by some oh that's
right here's the plus one exactly okay
good so summer we're gonna have to
represent this invariant and you know
which I could write down in logic as for
all I I is greater than 0 less than
table dot length implies blah but the
trouble is that you know these kinds of
universally quantified invariance get
much worse when you have fancier data
structures like lists and trees and such
for example imagine that instead of
storing it inside an array I store it
inside some kind of linked list so i
would have to say things like four
all X that is reachable by transitively
following the next pointer starting from
some root pointer x dot data is greater
than minus 1 so again you can devise
fancy logics that represent these things
but with all respect to Leo and Nicole I
SMT solvers don't don't play very well
with these for all's ok there's a it's a
it's a bit difficult to get them to to
deal with these kinds of universal
formulas and so what we've been trying
to figure out is is there a way that you
can represent these invariants these
universally quantified facts without
using explicit quantifiers or to put
another way can you somehow use some
different machinery to do the quantified
reasoning and the idea that we have is
the following is to essentially factor
the invariant to somehow split the
invariant up into two parts one is logic
the kind of you know simple predicates
that assembly solvers like to reason
about and a type ok so the standard type
systems and to somehow combine logic and
types in in a way such that the logic
can reason smoothly about individual
cells in the structure while the type
system deals with the heavy lifting
about quantifiers ok so this is this is
the goal so let me just show you some
examples if I have something like for
all I you know blah every element in the
table is greater than minus 1 the way I
might factor it into a logic and type is
like so I would say that the variable
table has the type it's an integer array
right so the green part is is just the
pure type integer array but I have this
little predicate that I stick that I
attached with the integer that says it's
an integer that's greater than minus 1
ok let me show you what happens with the
list if I have for all X something
something something I would just split
this into a type that said the variable
root is an integer list where each
integer is greater than minus 1 same
thing ok I've somehow factor the the
invariant it's the same invariant but
I've split it into into a into the green
part which is a type which is a type and
the blue part which is a logical
predicate and the key thing is that this
logical predicate is a very simple
predicate it has none of that nastiness
about the next star and the for all ok
and the idea is that the logic describes
individual structure
and so the theorem provers are SMT
solvers they can chew up those
predicates very easily well the type
system is going to give us a very simple
algorithm for dealing with structure for
doing this kind of quantified reasoning
okay and so at this point what I want to
do is swap out and show you I just want
to show you a demo of how this might
work so for many of you even if you
learn nothing else from this talk you
will learn about you will learn about
k-means clustering so here's let me just
walk you through this particular program
okay so first let me let me just comment
this out let's ignore that stuff and let
me just let me just push this button
because it'll generate a more color
coded version of that code oh sweet okay
let's ignore ignore all of those
assertion me feel okay for now and now
let me just let me just step you through
a program ok so this program has two
parts in the first part what I what I
build is a kind of is a toy MapReduce
implementation so a quick saw a survey
up is everyone here familiar with
MapReduce I shall I you are or not you
are everyone is okay so let me just step
through it very fast okay so it has
three steps yeah let's go through it
backwards so is everyone you're familiar
with F sharp this is Microsoft what's
your Excuse okay so I don't have to
explain what this means I love this that
little pipeline operator okay so okay
okay good so this is this is think of it
like a pipeline it's a pipeline operator
so what it means as take X's and pipe it
into this function take that result and
pipe it in the group and pipe that
result in the you know these three
functions so this basically says take
this input pipe it through one take that
output pipe it through to take the third
output pipe it through three it's little
brush volition
yeah I can show you the this is what it
is it's just it's a function that takes
X and F and it's just it's just
application backwards so good so at
least you get ok ok so one of the three
steps of MapReduce in the first step
what you do is you take you have a
mapping function that takes every
individual element and blows it out into
a list of key value pairs oh here we go
ok so you take each alpha and you blow
it out into a list of b's and c's
because you get so these are keys and
these are values in the second step what
you do is you use these keys to do a
group ok so you gather for each be you
build a table that for each bee finds
what is the list of sees that was
associated with that be in the in the
first step ok so this is step one this
is step two and then in the third step
what you do is you do a reduced which is
essentially a fold over this over this
see list okay so you fold over the sea
list okay so let me just you me to show
you the code ok so the first one is this
is just completely trivial I just I take
F my expansion function and I applied to
every element in the list ok quite
straightforward in the second step I do
this group by key okay so this is my
list of keys and values and I make a
little hash table and then I just jog
over each of the key value pairs I look
up you know what is currently what are
the what is the list of values
associated in the table with that key if
it's if it's if it's if such if the list
already exists then return that list
otherwise just start off with the empty
list and take whatever list I just
computed and add this new value V to it
right so I'm just adding one more
element stuff it back in the table and i
iterate over all the keys and values so
at the end I've clustered everything
inside the hash table and then I spit
out that table and then in the third
step which is this the reduced step I do
a fold where what I do is I do a
foldover the hash table so for each
wait why do i do a fold oh oh yes so I
yes so for each key valve for each key
and list of values as Bank barn in the
hash table I do a fall where I associate
that key with I basically fold over i
use the the reducing function f over all
the values that are associated with that
key ok now the key thing to notice is
that for MapReduce to work each key must
be associated with a non-empty list of
values right this is like an it's like a
non-null check you don't have keys in
this table that are associated with an
empty list of values and so you can use
the first value as the starting function
as the starting element that you fold
over ok and so you know if long as the
list is non-empty I take the first
element and I have the rest of the
elements and I just you know do a fold
and this list should never be empty so I
have a little assertion there that says
heaven forbid that this should be an
empty list oak you should never
associated key with an empty list so I
have a little assert etc etc and finally
the the MapReduce sort of just stitches
all of these steps together i take exes
I first expanded into the key values
then I collapse the key values to get a
hash table and then I call my collapsing
function with the reducing function to
get whatever the result is ok so far so
good now what I would like to prove is
that this assertion never fails ok so
that's one thing I would like to prove
but let's just keep the MapReduce in our
heads and let me just show you something
you might do with the MapReduce ok so
one of the one of the many popular
things that one can do with MapReduce is
something called k-means clustering how
many people here are familiar with gay
means clustering just threshold 023 very
good some people are okay so let me
briefly let me it's actually very simple
let me even I understand it with k-means
clustering you have a bunch of points ok
that's awful and you have a bunch of at
each step it's a kind of iterative
process ok at each step you have a bunch
of centers ok and in each step what what
a point does is it just figures out what
is the center that I'm nearest ok so you
have K centers hence the name came
each point figures out what is the
center that I'm nearest so it looks all
that's the distance of the center this
is these are the distance all so each
point says oh I'm near this guy i'm near
this guy me or this guy etc etc these
points maybes army of this guy etc etc
etc and then having figured this out you
compute a new center for this cluster
which is simply the addition of you know
it's the it's the weighted sum of all
the points that are in that particular
cluster right and then you you keep
repeating this until you think you found
what clusters okay so one way you might
do this with MapReduce is the following
let me just let me just show you how
this works it's um this is one of the
textbook examples of MapReduce is each
of you can paralyze this step where each
point tries to figure out which center
it's near okay and so I have a little
mapping function called nearest so
imagine you know it's all polymorphic
right so there's a k-means the mic a
means function takes n which is a number
of iterations to do this a distance
function that takes two points and
returns a float that says how far the
points are a plus function that I'm
going to use to find the centroid and
i'm going to add up all the points and
divide by the number of points on that
cluster ok i take in a list of points
that I want a cluster X's and I take in
a starting array of centers ok so this
array has you know these are the K
centers and I'm going to in each step
update the array so how am I going to do
this so I have a little for loop for 0
through n I take my points and I call a
MapReduce where the mapping function
simply finds out what is the nearest
center what which what's the nearest
Center for each point ok so what Nyriss
does is it returns well show you what it
does it finds the nearest center and the
reduced step computes the centroid
because once I figure out so the center
is essentially the key right this beta
is the is the center nearest center so
then I just cluster so this thus the I
at center it has these points in it ok
and then I just do a full this fold
computes the sum of all the points in
the center as well as the number of
points in that Center and so then I can
just update the center's by saying for
each door map right for each Center I
tau X is going to represent the sum of
all the points in the center SZ sighs
that represents how many points are in
the center so just update the center
array at for the IX center with X /
sighs okay so far so good how do we
compute the nearest well it's quite
Elementary this by distance function
these this array represents my current
centers and here's some arbitrary point
X right there's the thing that gets
paralyzed across all the points and so I
just compute a distance array which is a
map how you know I just I just map over
all my current centers at the distance
function so this tell me what is you
know this is my distance to the first
center this in second center third
center etc etc and then I call min index
on this da which represents which is the
index in the array that has the smallest
value so that's the nearest center right
so min index is you know it's a I've
deliberately written it in a very
iterative style so you don't accuse me
of only working with your functional
programs it's mean it looks pretty much
like see right I have a min which is
it's an imperative pointer i initialize
it with zero and then I just loop over
all the center or all the elements of
the array 40 through the length of the
array if the is element of the array is
less than the current minimum then
update the minimum to be to be I so I'm
just iterating over all the elements of
the array and in the end I return
whatever the main reference refers to so
this confuses the minimum so so min of
minion decks of da represents the
nearest Center and this simply says
return the point X itself as well as a
count one that says I am one there's
exactly one point because then the
reduced step is going to add up is going
to add up all these ones and is going to
tell me how many points there are in
each Center ok ok good so we're all on
the on we're all on the we all
understand how MapReduce works so what
could possibly go wrong so here are
several things that might that might
well this pesky assert might fail where
have we gone this pesky assertion might
fail so I would like to be sure that
this assertion never fails let's keep
going Here I am touching these arrays no
wrong example
Here I am touching I'm reading this
array a dot I this may not be within
bounds this may not be within bounds
what else might happen little jog along
right here i'm updating this i'm
updating this centered I this may not be
within bounds and the thing i want to
emphasize is that this is pretty much
touching all of the things that software
verification algorithm suck at in the
sense that where's this i coming from we
got this I out by calling MapReduce okay
so we're calling this higher order
function MapReduce with these two things
and it's spitting it out as a list of
values after having put them inside some
hash table where did the grouping by key
etc etc etc right so these are all
things that have traditionally been
rather tedious to deal with and you need
a very fancy logics to represent
invariance like this so now let me show
you how one so what is it okay so so I
what I did is I switched off all the
checking and so this is all the possible
places where assertions might fail or
line 50 is the non null these are all
the various places where we touch arrays
okay all of those might fail actually
there's one more place whether something
might fail which I dunno if you kept
your eye on was this divide by 0 how do
I know that this sizes is not 0 right I
mean you and I know it because we
started off with one and then plus is
just adding up the size but still how do
i and i'm doing this fancy fold thing
how do I know that it's it's not going
to they can also be overflows very good
which we have to want it on okay so
first actually one of the things i want
to show you is how might i actually
there is by the way I don't have anyone
can spot this but there is a bug in this
in the sense that if i call k-means with
certain inputs I can cause this program
to throw an array exception can anyone
tell me what that input might be this
does not work for all arrays
exactly right so if the array of centers
is empty then all hell can break loose
for example this min over any just crazy
stuff can happen okay and so what I
would need is a nice way to specify a
contract that says that you should only
call this with you know arrays that are
non empty and I also want a contract so
notice that it's one of these things
where I'm passing into k-means a
division operation so I want to say that
I'm giving you this division but for
God's sake go and call division with a
non 0 with 0 right so how would one
specify this contract it turns out that
it's very convenient to do in this in
this type based style so let me just
quickly show you that before a blah blah
blah okay here we go it's ignore matrix
multiply so here's what it looks like is
this chrome drat it should be just okay
so k-means thanks and this plus blah
blah blah so noted okay so i can specify
that the division operation the second
argument that I pass it must not be 0
okay so i can say div takes an alpha
some integer and it turns an alpha but
that integer must not be 0 and where did
that array of centers go here we go okay
so I ki have to pass in a center array
whose length is greater than 0 okay and
then you know various think good things
will happen okay so this how I might
specify a contract but having done so
what is it that the user needs to do is
just to write down these little program
fragments sorry these predicates
fragments like I plus J equals n minus 1
but it's slightly more convenient so let
me just show you what some of these look
like so this just ripped this just says
use any you can use as an app you can
use as a program fragment anything that
looks like value remember that V that we
had V greater than minus 1 so this is V
V is greater than or less than any other
program variable that I just represent
by an underscore this says that you can
also use as a program fragment something
of the form V is less than a radar
length of any program array okay so this
can match with anything and finally to
prove that arraign not to prove that
that list to prove that that lisp
assertion does not get violated what I'm
going to do is I'm going to define a
notion of lengths for this okay so
length is going on it's a recursive
function it's just says one length of is
ex-con sex 1 plus room and the empty
list is 0 and so I'm going to throw in a
little prayer an atomic fragment that
says you may also use in your invariance
predicates of the form the length of
some list is greater than 0 or greater
than or equal to 0 so strictly greater
than or greater than equal to and you
can make up whatever little fragments
you like okay so in this particular case
these are just the three fragments that
I picked and now i'm going to push this
little button and all of these warnings
are going to go away and i'll sort of
i'll just show you why they go away this
is where unfortunately things start to
get slightly ugly but let me just show
you what invariant it computes for the
stuff that goes into this hash table so
check it out so this hash table t it
says that the elements in this hash
table it's an it's a hash table of alpha
and and a list of values remember is the
clustered thing where that lists has the
length of that list is greater than 0
strictly greater than 0 of course
greater than 0 means it's also greater
than or equal to 0 so you have this
annoying fellow in there but you have
this ring and because it can prove this
about the hash table when it does this
folding when it does the folding it
knows that each of these v's each of
those lists is each of those lists is
such that is this readable unclear oh
this is not I don't even know where to
look well this is this basically the
less strength if you it knows that each
of these lists is is is is a has length
strictly greater than 0 and you knows
that the empty list has length equal to
0 and so essentially this is dead code
this can never fire right because that
that match never happens what's that
between is what we are where does it say
it actually it says it right here it
says I'm in two places as previously
servicer it's a conjunction know let's
let's let me look I to parse it I need
to switch back and see what exactly the
type of fold is kV Zack okay good so the
first argument of fold is a function
that takes three arguments right T
values and ack and values is the thing
where we want this non-empty invariant
to hold so let's just look at the type
of fold over here come on buddy okay
good so three arguments remember first
argument which is the key alpha the
second argument which is values and this
is where it knows that it's a vet if
it's a list whose length is strictly
greater than zero what's the third one
to decide ik's a comprehension there
three very good oh so there's a
conjunction second job yes yes Sam
subsume the others friend you know yeah
we'll just dump it over ideally we
should we should do some minimization
but don't let me start it okay right
okay so that's why this one checks out
right this why this assertion passes
let's jog along and see what happens
with k-means let's see what what type we
get four min index because this one is
quite easy for min index we see that we
take an input some random array a and
the out Oh whose length is greater than
zero which is quite crucial which comes
out of the fact that we only call this
function with arrays that are non empty
and the output is a number that's
greater than 0 and less than the length
of a that's what min index is yeah
it's are not showing it I'm sorry V is
implicitly bound away you should read
this as V colon int it I'm just trying
to save real estate on this slide it
really is V colon int we've like yeah
okay let's see what type you get four
nearest four nearest i get i get as
input why is this mouse moving okay i
pass in some dysfunctions I'm count you
know Center array some point X and the
output that I get is a list of values no
hang on oh it's just some list Oh drat
I'm it's suppressing the printer it's a
list of values that that's greater than
zero it should actually say what that
list is but I switched it off my
apologies this is useless
unfortunately user interface design is
not my strong point isn't it nice that
this is pretty fast ah great okay now
shield your eyes for a second because it
made this is why okay so what I get is
that the output is a list where each
element in the list is greater than 0
and less than a radar length of the
center area okay so it's a valid index
there's another thing actually that you
get which is that the second element in
the list is remember you actually get a
tuple right of the point which is alpha
and one and so instead of one what it
says is it's a value that's greater than
zero okay and this is the thing that's
going to accumulate when we add it up
and it's going to help us prove that the
division doesn't crash let's keep going
centroid centroid is pretty simple
simple centroid just says that it takes
as input tuples where the second element
is greater than zero and in the output
the two output tuple is also greater
than zero okay and so finally when you
stitch it all together in this map
reduce all of these accesses are within
bounds this particular just a second
Nikolai this I is between zero and the
length of Center array and this size is
strictly greater than zero okay wonder
if we can actually look at it this is
going to blow up sorry this is hideous
it's in there somewhere if you if you
squint very hard but let me take your
question yeah the example uses a sh t
you
type and the annotation in fact is
abstracted to do create a model for you
or if you just your analysis
it doesn't look at it only uses the type
signature of hash tables so in fact in
this particular case I don't even really
i only use the type for MapReduce which
looks something like that so i can
describe how i guess i will remains to
be seen if i have time for that hashtag
en masse reduce weight I don't even know
where that when a folder would up so you
have one place where you insert you have
to guess where forward yes yes and the
values in serving to the hash table with
it to perform yes and you get that just
by the types even just from the time
signature that's just in lehman lets you
know i'll be i'll find one place this
pipes into the you know the input in the
second pic so it just ends up you define
proximate yeah so basically when the
method when the MapReduce implementation
is being analyzed as being analyzed
completely independent of of all these
clients it has no idea about you know as
it can't okay so now let me just swap
back and show you I think we have we
have some time right we can let me show
you a bit about how exactly all of this
really happened I kind of wave my hands
really fast and in particular what I
want to do is I want to step through
some of these features and how they get
handled okay so your base types you have
collections are lists etc hash tables
closures and generics and I just want to
show you how nicely you know the type
system combines with all of that
invariant machinery that I talked about
you know at the at the start of the top
okay so let's start off with base types
okay let's start off with base types and
let me just so this is a snippet that
was there i was using i wrote a for loop
as a function and the way the for loop
works is it takes a lower bound l and
upper bound you and a function f that is
called at each step and it is very
simple level is less than you then call
F on l and follow that up by recursively
calling f4 with l plus 1 you f so i use
this you remember there was a for loop
that jogged over the array to find the
minimum element okay now as far as the
language is concerned the type of this
function f is just intero unit okay this
function f it takes as input some in
l and it turns as output a unit if the
any step that's all it does so how am I
going to figure out what you know what
is this you know this liquid type for F
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
generate a little template okay where
I'm going to say well it's some special
kind of integer I don't know what kind
so I'm going to create a little variable
just like we had before okay a little
purple x 1 i'm going to integer aero
unit and now what I'm going to do is I'm
going to look at how f gets used i'm
just going to generate a bunch of
subtyping constraints and those are
going to give me constraints on this x1
okay so let's see the one place where f
gets called is over here actually I'm
lying over here I wonder if you'll
figure out where what is right here what
I call F with the argument n right so
let's see what really happens so you can
think of it as L flowing into the input
of F right this guy is the input of F
and so I end up with a sub typing
constraint that looks like this the
value equals to L that guy flows into
the input of F which is this guy right
x1 this particular flow happens under
that branch right where l is less than
you and so I say when l is less than you
this subtyping happens and now this
little subtyping constraint is actually
an implication in this guy's just like
the implications we had before it simply
reduces to l is less than u and v is
equal to l implies x is equal eyes x1
just like those invariance we had before
it's exactly the same thing ok and so I
can use exactly that same machinery with
the atoms and what-have-you which is
what those those little underscore
things were and I get that the liquid
type of F is I when I solve out for x1 I
get that I get this conjunction v is
greater than L and less than you ok if
you think about it this satisfies this
particular implication and I just plug
it in into that template x1 and I get
that the liquid type of F is it only
gets called with integers that are
greater than L and less than you and the
output is unit yeah it can have this
junction yes ok and this is what allows
me to deduce by the way that remember
how we were computing the main index if
you if we just step back to the code for
a second if you look at how the four was
so check it out over
when I was computing min index this I is
going to be between zero and array dot
length because this what allows me to
deduce that is between l and you ok so
that was easy enough let's look at
collections ok so first let me look at
this to pass one can look at collections
one is the actual contents of the
collection what did I put inside the
list and two is what can I say about the
list itself how long is it things like
that ok so let's look first at structure
which is this business of length so this
is the grouping function remember where
we we clustered by by the key right so
this is the group function and let me
just focus on these two lines i compute
the current values associated with the
key and then i take my new value which
was v's was V and I add that and I stuff
it into the hash table ok so that's what
this looks like now here are some of the
types so as far as the language is
concerned the type of the hash table T
is an alpha-beta list hash table so it
maps a key alpha to a list of data and
the value the type of this variable v's
is a list of betas right which I'm going
to them right back into thing so as
before i'm just going to generate
templates the hash table is a hash table
of betas sorry beta list such that X 1
and X the variable v's is a list of beta
such that X 2 just as before and now
notice that in this branch this value
flows into v's right I look up the value
of whatever is associated with key Nash
in the hash table T and I flow it in 2
v's and so this yellow thing whose type
is this guy right this is the elements
of the hash table this flows into v's
and so i end up with a subtyping
constraint like so this left-hand side
is a subtype of this right-hand side so
this is really the reasoning that
happens with the hash table which of
course simplifies to X 1 implies X 2
quite Elementary yeah when it is finally
ready case
you can but that causes the beyond the
scope of this talk you can talk about
everything oh right okay x 1 is right
less than x 2 great where was I oh the
other thing that flows into v's is the
empty list right so there's an
if-then-else so both of these guys flow
into these so the empty list simply it
looks like this remember the empty list
is a list whose length is equal to 0 so
Len v is equal to 0 is also a subtype of
this guy which simplifies onto this okay
so that's two more implication
constraints and finally this guy over
here gets written into the hash table
right I call hash table dad with this
and so what I end up with is that this
guy v konce v's whose type is len v is
equal to ln v plus 1 remember the type
of the length function ok is a subtype
of x1 which is the contents of the hash
table so i end up with a third subtyping
constraint that looks like this where
v's has the type x 2 and this simplifies
down through yet another implication
constraint which is just this when x to
you know take whatever you know about x2
and substitute the value variable V for
fees can join that with this fact that
must imply x1 most more of these
implication constraints and now these
get solved out to x1 is equal to ln v is
greater than zero okay and x2 is equal
to ln v is greater than or equal to 0
because of this pesky equals and as a
consequence i can conclude that the hash
table when i plug the results back in is
a hash table of values where each list
has length strictly greater than 0 ok
yeah include information
and clean faster news all over for
example let me ask you simple just to
save real estate and just for simplicity
right in here in reality it's all there
it's like a blizzard of stuff let me
just show you where I cheated I'm
surprised nobody caught me on this click
click click for example over here look
at this I said I i remember i put out
this one constraint i didn't even
involve this plus how can it be that
this plus is not involved because if i
put l minus 1 clearly this type would
not hold right i don't call it between
uln you if i start decrementing the
lower bound so what happened did I cheat
no actually I just left out there's
another constraint because of the fact
that I've long story suffice it decided
to for clarity okay no I don't actually
because that is not pure in this case in
this example you don't say anything
about the posting of your every school
sorry sorry Bobby yes I don't so my
tightness has no information about the
posted so in particular remember the f
we pass and had a pointer had that main
index that we're playing games with the
type tells me nothing about that all it
tells me is what it just tells me what
prick what inputs f is called with ok so
I'm only refining that which is explicit
in the type if you want to talk about
things like state mutation you put it
into the type so you just you know you
use some sort of mana trickery you just
bang it into the time ok but here I
don't care f need not be pure in fact it
is not pure in the example I showed you
ok click click click structure great
length mumble let's just move along let
me show you one more quick example yes
yes so the one problem if you're going
to infer
basically contracts beyond these types
is that your interfaces in your library
just implementing so specific things
about information that is being too
specific right there and Lady you might
change it yo you're stuck with it yeah
even I hear about it I don't but frankly
that happens with types too I mean this
is just a general problem with contracts
I I know this happens with type 2 i'm in
the middle of this right now i'm i'm
doing a bunch of refactoring you know
there's some stuff in the type signature
as I oh no I shouldn't have exposed this
information because now there's all
these other modules I'd use this
information and well you have to suck it
up and just make the change but no I
don't have an it actually gets worse
over here right because you are exposing
even more information about these
invariants and so on so I mean this is
like an API design question and to be
quite honest I don't have a good answer
you just forced away with the right now
oh yeah the liquid time is there hope
for the interfaces and I do right
because in this case if you recall in
the demo I actually for this I expect
that you will write down I mean if it's
an open program I want to allow modular
verification and so you can specify you
know there's another matrix multiply but
let's ignore that here's a signature for
K means that gets checked so it's just
like you take the you know the ml I or
the you know you declare some function
to be method to be public so you would
for public methods you could write down
a signature if you wanted to and then I
would you know check that the client you
know if I give a more specific type
liquid night then the one you refer with
able to check to avert the implication
yes as long as it's as long as the
implementation is a subtype of the
contract it doesn't in fact in this
particular case notice the contract just
as value is not equal to zero but my
implementation is stronger right it's
actually value strictly greater than
zero so that's fine so the actual check
is that the implementation is a subtype
of the contract okay okay it doesn't
have to be exactly the same okay let's
yeah isn't it a good idea for
programmers to specify these liquid
types
rather what do you put a loaded question
um just what I think I think for certain
functions you should specify the types
for example those interface functions ok
so for interface functions it is it
really makes software engineering sense
to specify the types you'd be a fool not
to but if you want to go back to this
little MapReduce example if I had to
specify the types everywhere I would
just die because in addition to
specifying the ties for you know a
little bit ly things like f4 and learn
and expand and blah blah blah blah blah
each of these guys one of the things
that people miss out is that when you
involve genetics and polymorphism you
have to also tell me the type for each
polymorphic instantiation point okay so
for example at this place where I
innocently say something like oh this is
the wrong example but actually
everywhere right over here I say min min
equals ref ref zero I would have to
specify up the refinement that told me
this is between you know zero is between
this values between 0 and the length of
the array a so it's like think of Java
and all its verbosity you know think of
Java or C sharp minus the nice VAR and
local type inference where every time
you declare a list you have to say oh
it's a list of Em's or a list of
stringer now in addition you have to
tell me what exactly you know what is
the logical predicate for each of these
places right and polymorphism once you
went once yours once polymorphism slips
into the language is everywhere so this
would just be a word it would really
inundate you and so it's very very
useful to be able to infer these things
otherwise I think this stuff is useless
frankly but at the same time everything
should not be you know if you everything
is not completely automatic because
honestly this is an open program I don't
know how this is going to be called so I
want to say you should not call me with
you know with arrays that are of length
equal to zero
when we insert connected connections
yeah you haven't filed the earth exists
yeah yeah so I kind of top-level global
declarations that's a very useful place
to put in but you don't want to have it
put in everywhere because then it's kind
of it get slim and just makes everything
on renumber um okay maybe we should just
you know I could go on and on oh let me
just show you this one last example then
I'll stop okay so this is the function
that computed the you know for each
point it this is the the map step in the
MapReduce rain it computes for each
point the cell that is the center that
its nearest and the point itself comma 1
is we're going to add up those points so
now the output type and I'm removing
some parentheses for space is int this
is an int x this is a beta times an
interest and so I'm going to generate a
template that looks like that I'm just
going to make up those x 1 x tools and
now the type of array dot map is so this
one of those things when i put into the
specification of a radar map because
it's a common use library function that
it takes an a mapping function an array
x and the output array is has the same
length as the input array x that's what
this says and so as a consequence the
type of da this distance array is that
its length is equal to the center array
because that's what i got from there and
now when i do min index of da it's it's
type is that is between zero the output
values between 0 and length of da just
going to i'm just going to plug in the
type of main index that got inferred and
as a consequence for this entire output
this this whole value flows into the
output of the function i end up with a
subtyping relation that looks like this
this is the actual concrete
implementation time frame main index da
is a value that's greater than 0 less
than len da x is a beta and one is off
type value equals one and i generate a
list of these things list and the
right-hand side is this template which
is the output type of of this function
so i end up with this subtyping
relationship which again just reduce
to these two sub type in plication I get
one implication for x1 this guy implies
X 1 and this guy implies X 2 but I have
this thing in the environment that da is
off type the length of da is equal to
the length of Center array so i end up
with two implications that look like
this and again i solve them out you know
so I've so this is this what I meant by
the type system deals with the nasty
quantification because here I am saying
you know for all elements in the list
etc etc type system just says mumble a
list less than B list means a less than
B and end up with these two implications
and I get this as my output okay that
it's a list of it's a list of values
where the key the center is between zero
and the length of the center array which
is essential for proving the rebound
safety when I update the center's and
that the you know the point the position
that holds whether or not it's you know
how many points are there inside that
cluster is greater than zero which is
what proves the division safety let me
just you know mrs. blah blah blah let me
cut to the Loom each is very quickly cut
to the end so this very nice demo blah
blah blah generics there were generics
all over the place and actually the the
high-level bit is it's very simple you
have the type of map produces this ml
instantiates alpha with alpha beta with
something see with something right at
each call site this is you know what ml
or C sharp when you have a polymorphic
thing you instantiate it with some
concrete type all we do is we just say
oh you instantiate beta with integer I'm
going to instantiate with integer such
that X 1 you instantiate see with eight
times in I'm going to instantiate it
with a times in such that X 2 okay and
then I just plug it back into the
template same thing works again you just
grind down a bunch of subtyping reduces
to a bunch of implications and you get
back these are these nice types and so
the high-level bit is that with vanilla
programs from the 60s this is the style
right you have these program point in
variance and you generate these
implication constraints and you solve
them and in order to deal with these
richer programming features you just
generalize things to involve types use
the types to deal with the parts of the
impairment that are tedious reason about
with your improvers so you end up with
in representing invariance in this kind
of factored form at
you end up with subtyping relation we
generalize the vanilla implication but
which crunch down into implications and
then the same sort of abstract
interpretation machinery will will give
you the invariance let me just tell you
about some of the things we use this
form so right now I described everything
in terms of ml but in recent work we've
actually made this work for see as well
so you take in the program together with
assertions and you take in those little
atoms those fragments with the
underscores and you get as output either
it says safe all the types lineup as
well as the type for you to view or
it'll say oh I can't type check this
particular operation some some type
error on line 38 as well as the types
and actually one of the nice things
about about this particular style
instead of the purely model checking
approach where you just say thumbs up or
here's a counter example is even when
you fail even when the system can't
prove whatever property one it tells you
the Tykes actually tell you what it
knows so I can't tell you over here that
you know X is between a and B but I can
tell you that is greater than E and so
it's a good clue to figure out what's
going wrong or you know what where you
might make made a mistake we thrown
around a bunch of fancy data structure
so this is actually moderns question
what can you how rich are these
invariants and it turns out they're
really quite rate so for example we
looked at the implementation of finite
maps from the o camel implement standard
library these are implemented as AVL
trees so he's a height balanced trees
these are just all the grizzly stuff you
see in your sort of data structures
class you in surgical rotation rebalance
what have you and we can represent and
very rapidly infer things like the tree
is always binary search order so the
root all the keys to the left that are
smaller to the left all the trees all
the key is greater to the right that the
tree is actually hide balanced and that
you don't drop any keys all the keys
that are supposed to be in the map are
in the map here's an even more fancy
data structure this is binary decision
diagrams which no doubt you're all
familiar with yeah this is
the invariance yes yes we have to tell
it what you want right yes it is
everything froze yes so vdd is also it's
an acyclic graph representation for
boolean formulas and the what you want
to verify is that along each path the
variables are in strictly increasing
order right so x1 and the child is has
to be greater than X 1 need not be x2 in
something greater and this actually uses
you know it uses some fancy hash table
trickery to to do this sharing and still
we can you know we can represent
invariance like the variable ordering
invariant and we've thrown out a bunch
of you know very complicated data
structure so beyond just things like
array bounds checking and the point of
this is is simply that this is a very
expressive mechanism it's not limited to
a rebalance checking we've also recently
applied this to see so we that was a
fair bit of work but it's still very
preliminary so the benchmarks are really
quite small and for see we've just
looked at spatial memory safety that is
say the absence of buffer overflows and
aldi references and these are all tiny
programs but the interesting thing about
the programs is that these are all
things that are entirely beyond the
scope of you know automated analysis
before and the reason they will and the
reason they will be on automated
analysis is because all of these like
the MapReduce example have key
invariance flowing through data
structures like a raised linked lists
and sort of arbitrary DAGs ok and the
the nice thing about this sort of hybrid
type logic mechanism is that you can
represent those invariance really in
pretty much the same way as that
MapReduce example that I showed you but
of course this is really very
preliminary that's pretty much it let me
stop now and let everybody go to lunch
and and take more questions thanks
figure out something that builds on
you're interested in modular
verification that we have mutations
supposed to job some classical radio
spots that somehow induces
hash table yes and and the radio wants
the hash table to have exactly five five
elements and now it calls a routine in
the library that's that parties for
those with a hash table in some private
parties imagine okay modified really and
where how you write the specification
that that you want it to be a place 5
and where does the error we're going to
check these are both very good questions
let's pick the first one first because
that I have an answer to the way you
would write it is pretty much the same
thing that I showed you for list length
okay where how am I so for Liz I wrote
this recursive function for hash tables
or in general can I basin and looking
for an eraser ah sorry what you would do
is or actually like a red dot length for
that matter what we've gone the the way
let me show you what really happens with
a red dot length right when I have you
know the array is basically you ever get
in a set right and so what I give I give
the get method a type that says that you
taken an array array and some index I so
this is the vanilla ml type and I get as
output an alpha right now what I've done
is I've gone inside the array module and
I've given it a liquid type that says
ray called X let's just say X and an
integer which is some value V that's
between zero and the length of length of
X and I get us out put an alpha so to do
your hash table thing what I would do is
I would you know define some notion of
hash table size let's just say I have a
hash table dot size or dot length or
something like that and then what i
would do is um let's just call that
module my hash ok or hash five or
something what i would do is i would say
that that each of the hash tables inside
that that was created inside that module
was v of type hash t such that size of v
is equal to five or less than five if
you prefer and I would give the gate and
the set methods a proof so I would give
the get method for example it takes as
input a hash table such a you know of
this size and some key alpha and it
produces a better user yes yes but I
want to use the you want to enforce this
session I hope he has a standard
implementation of hash table yes yeah
yeah so let's get this one be written in
a user and a half stable so you have to
here's the standard library let's call
it hash table and let's say I have my or
restricted hash table implementation
that uses this guy right and so let's
call that hash five or something like
that you want to use the same
implementation but I would put the
specification in the interface for hash
five that's where I would put it to
Rivera Phi the implementation of hashed
it no I don't because the hash table is
it that is going to maintain that two
areas that you've written on board so
this guy doesn't have to maintain that
invariant right it's just tables that I
create over here that have to maintain
that invariant you see what I'm saying I
verify it I verify that any client that
uses hash five never adds you know so
whenever I have a client that you know
creates a hash 5t that that client you
know the size of all those t's is less
than five and you know for all I know
hash five dot T also creates instances
of hash five dot T it's not you know
maybe when you add some other function
so i would have to maintain that
invariant inside that as well so i would
check it I would you know I would ride I
would write a signature for the getters
and setters that are implemented for
hash 5t because they don't know for
arbitrary hash tables right the only one
for these guys the special class of hash
tables and you know any any calls made
to those getters and setters inside this
would be checked and any calls made to
the getters to the getters and setters
by clients would also be checked against
that interface the other implementations
inside this they would use the bear hash
tables so for that I wouldn't have this
very stranger I wouldn't even have this
size criteria
maybe I would just you know add to the
set method something that says that I
take as input a hash table and I produce
as output a hash table whose sizes the
input size plus one or something to that
effect okay the actual implementation
that since the only one hash table
doesn't guarantee those properties every
rap are going to introduce some hash
five has to actually do a dynamic check
how does it know that bass
implementation doesn't you know screw up
wait I didn't follow this bit about the
dynamic check what you're saying the
underlying hash table doesn't know about
these constraints so if those
constraints are only enforced in ash
five how do you know that when it calls
the underlying operations in a hash
rotation because whenever I in
properties there is something i'm using
from the underlying hash which is that
every time i add a key the size goes up
by one do you see what I'm saying so I
am using that I'm just not using this
business about it's less than five or
less than whatever bound but I am using
the fact that the underlying hash
correctly tracks the size of any given
hash table does that make sense so that
bit of work is going to be done over
here but the extra invariant enforcement
happens over here Nicole I look faction
of the weather is starting the hostage
yes and that is in this size in that you
know hash not sighs yeah well I mean you
obviously some sort of set right yes
anyway you could even do that in fact we
do even do that you know when I
mentioned this thing about the
the oak amel finite map so when I said
it Keys implementer set that's what I
meant when you do add one of the you
know so just like I showed you a list on
length you can write a list contents and
you can write for a map you can write a
content function and so one of the
things we check for map is that the add
method so add takes a takes a map and a
and an X and it returns as output a new
map whose contents are equal to the old
map union with X and the remove
similarly takes you know does the set-
and so on and so forth so you could
write all of these in there in the map
implementation distant can see you go
there sometime based I might have to go
every verify and strengthen they made
absolutely that because for example when
i designed the hash maybe i didn't care
about this size business at all so the
original signature didn't you know
didn't contain any information so the
way to think about it is that the type
signature is an abstraction of what the
rest of the world cares about this
particular module and if later i want
more information that i'm going to have
to revisit the abstraction you're
absolutely right about that so let me
actually give you one of the weaknesses
of the system since you mentioned a very
interesting point is one of the things I
showed you is that you know MapReduce
uses fold right and fold is actually
wonderful because it packs a lot of
information inside the type but one
piece of information it does not back is
how many times does the folding function
get called when you have a list that's
just not there in the ml type you could
write your own version of fold that has
done but it's not there in the ml type
and so in some sense i'm using the type
as a kind of baseline abstraction that
I'm you know adding more information to
but some information has already been
thrown away and you know that's you just
have to live with that